yeah hello and welcome to this live
stream I hope this works this is
essentially a test stream and trying to
check it out if twitch streaming this
work just like that let's say I have
this channel or I had this channel for
very long time for years but never used
it I did the hot stream on YouTube but
which seems to offer much better get
technical possibilities so I'm trying to
stream here on Twitch in the future I
guess let's see how this works out if
somebody is actually watching it repeat
lies to get a message in the chat there
should be a connection also to the DHS
starting site going to the star nice
idea which means the front page you know
that [ __ ] seems to be live I hope that
works ok there is not yet I'm not yet on
the front page here anyway
let's actually play some chess know that
we are on and it looks basically ok
technically um what do I play I think
I'm going to yeah do the hourly super
blitz arena let's do it and join yeah I
guess it's very unlikely that I have
actually some spectator because my
channel is sound really active so they
don't think I'm connected on a front
page orphanages at the moment so and I
have a Sicilian defense here white plate
yeah something that is I'm not sure what
that is
looks a bit like a qua pre-attack but a
little bit odd I know he has to he had
to take what he did is give me give me
the c3 pawn for not that much I think
this is a good move Knight situate I'm
threatening to win the Queen oh that's
the Queen can almost free move Knight
takes he won the Queen is completely
trapped so just grab the Queen yeah I
could have berserk dad but you know I
was more worried about the technique
technical side of things I really wonder
if this is working because I would have
thought I have at least somebody in the
chat I always want somebody job hi there
okay what do we do him what am I doing
here I can take the pawn probably that's
not bad yeah hi guys yeah I'm trying
this out I mean I know that it should
sure I know that it should work because
the channel is is there I have it stored
I had to set it up on Twitch and see
yeah if it if it works but it seems to
work basically right out of the box yeah
I'm thinking about about this doing
basically the videos as streams so
whatever if I'm doing like a video here
to do an arena tournament or some rapid
game you're just doing it on Twitch and
it will be archived on YouTube anyway
but it has them the benefit of yeah
being able to connect
with the chat which is nice and um it's
not essentially let's say more work for
me I mean if I'm doing a local recording
on stream stream the whole thing to
twitch this is not a difference in any
way I'm thinking about it them it makes
sense in many ways okay so here I'm
trying to drum up an attack on the G
file and I mean it is an open file
already it looks dangerous
the only issue is that I have this funky
look on a seven if I would be able to
cancel long no I did not look at the
tightest sto coverage at all
I wasn't actually I didn't actually know
that they had a round today I thought
the headrest a so yeah here I'm going
for mate King f1 Queen f3 is made and
kingi one Queen GeForce also leading to
mate
it would have been a good Boozer King
game that
yeah hindsight is 20/20
are there any exciting games in the tata
steel tournament today the good thing is
they have they have the two groups which
means fourteen games and yeah back in
the day they made three groups there was
21 games it was almost impossible to not
have anything interesting which makes
some it's much more fun than just having
a small tournament where you have three
games going on I have one questions I
don't know if you can tell me am i
featured on the starting page of on the
main page of Li chess as a stream or not
yeah that that would be that would be
interesting to learn
I really like to know that I could I
could check him I don't know if I how I
can check it actually yeah I have a
chest or open the title but probably
have to link the twitch account yeah I
probably have to link the twitch account
here in my in my settings on my streamer
settings
do I have to us is that the thing maybe
yes sir I haven't no I haven't looked at
this I think somewhere here there is
something the streamer manager this this
is probably where I have to do something
this is a new feature the streamer
manager of course yeah I think I go d5
if he plays takes takes if I have I have
to check on a form so that it looks like
an annoying thing to face I keep
forgetting to preserve but often times
some oh that that looks terrible
okay so I can take f-7m you okay that's
good enough
so this pawn is a real nuisance how to
how to finish this off maybe something
like we need for will whoa okay
I'm quite happy that this rook is traded
because this is one of his rare pieces
that actually takes pawn in the game the
King on her Wow
okay it's it's hard to believe then this
should hold em but how do I do it
how do I win this I can do it I can go
here and have Queen f5 lined up but I'm
blundering this okay Queen f5 is still
going to be very dangerous game chick so
I take here
don't find a winner that's kind of
embarrassing there should be a wind Jake
you okay I'm checking this again and
then then see do I have something better
here I don't see it I don't see it takes
Queen takes seems to hold for the moment
IKEA so King g7 he will play
and okay if a day this is somehow ruling
yeah this is crazy why is this not
winning remarkable
they just don't see a wind trying to get
drew kf3 into this but I mean he he
doesn't have many moves and I thought
that that's definitely the case takes
root chicks isn't even so clear but I
can go route D - G - maybe you can milk
the King mmm exactly
okay I hope she - though it's still a
pin
and okay some made Wow
and let that I already had some issues
that I didn't didn't didn't look that
great okay so I'm going to quickly check
this hour to the streamer manager you
YouTube channel you to which I can just
explained without the e I have no time
together I know what have let's do let's
submit you are ready to be listed okay I
don't know where was a tournament again
yep I have to rejoin okay I'm on 5th
place let's see what happens how many
viewers does the stream have by the way
I have this I have a page there I don't
see it yeah how many do we have
I'm not sure if my setup here that's
great okay I cou okay let's go E for him
10 oh that's glamorous okay like we can
get again higher things are better
linked yeah this already is a pretty
nice position
already have a nice pollution let's see
I taking only six a simple and good and
yeah the d6 pawn does not look very
beautiful
mmm I don't know there are many good
moves he actually this one I don't know
quite a couple of good mouse taking
Queen B 3 would be quite awkward Jake
will be three okay I'm not threatening
mate but it's close not be seven hangs
but it's not not help all that much if I
kick him here where's he going
and it's same nights is six I can take
on b7 I'll kick this again yeah I wonder
if this is so great actually what I did
probably not yeah I probably had
something better
yep that is the issue he's got this
central square all of a sudden and okay
I'm not unhappy here but I felt oh I
should have actually more
not easy firm and against problems to
move pieces him night of an age six is
stuck the e6 night cannot move and this
is a very as well
Wow okay I'm quitting takes takes the e6
knight is pinned and the way is the
night going in the first place I don't
know what to see five on how is he goes
back well um so how do we do that that
doesn't quite work
maybe I just do this trade them the
important Bishop them the other night
has no square Sam if I go here
where is he doing where is it covering
it there kingi several f6 f6 check so
I'm picking this up and he sacrifices
piece maybe I should have gone Queen
between age six
oh okay got this chick okay
maybe him I'm one g6 okay how does it
cover each 700 isn't
[Music]
okay I've got a scribe message there so
um okay I'm on second place already um
let's get this on the road and see how
okay
she just might be too pawn yeah the b3
museum does not fit all that well with
them with the Bishop f4 development it's
not like terrible but it doesn't add up
so much yeah so probably I have to go
all the way back and this is d4 or this
was d4 to be more precise so he's given
me the whole center that's motive ah
shoot I felt okay Bishop e7 and then h6
and then I played h6 first how silly is
that that's one of the rare vase to lose
this game
oops oops oops oops yeah I still have to
set the pause so I will yeah 93 as a
self pin unfortunately with Queen d2
but I have to get get something going
ham let's cover the Queen and now I can
actually take I mean my pawn structure
is not good but I've got three pawns and
maybe I can get me 396 however is some
quite a problem well played him he's
played dead well if I get b3 I think I
have at least some chances to not lose
the game
it's still difficult to to winders
not good not good at all
it's got all the way covered like b6 b7
he can just push this and I have known I
mean b6 I have covered at least yeah I
can't stop fights but um is there a
threat night th it's mostly a check is
giving me this okay
yeah I mean I don't think it's
particularly easy to win
maybe if I blunder some mortgage if I'm
not blundering an additional parlor so
it gets it gets tricky it gets tricky it
gets tricky let's go here
okay this No
and self-covered okay I can check him
here actually and check him again for d3
which doesn't really make it b7 coming
let's do this I think I can do this I'm
not playing well yeah okay I keep posing
problems oops oops I have a complete
completely messed up desk space yeah
nice kiss got be ADA covered yeah
so I've got a completely ridiculous end
game here night against Bishop and night
which is of course drawn but yeah it's
not just draw technically you can you
can try to win this on time you can
absolutely not win this ending I had
this on the board once in a tournament
game okay so it's oh my god that was a
pretty bad game and no it's not my first
which stream but like yeah almost
it's been years yeah I've done I've done
one before or a couple before a YouTube
offered live streams and then I did
someone YouTube okay so we have the
Scandinavian you know this is a good
line from white immediately
wait it's it's like so long ago
maybe I guess it doesn't count hmm I
surely played Queenie - probably
this is 94 here right f94 him it's maybe
not such a big issue let's go here and
the night night discovery is kind of
irritating for black oh okay so I'm
happy if he gives me the bishop here
yeah it looks okay that looks really
okay
so f 1 and 4 F 5 coming f4 let's go at 5
it's not brilliant it's nice but it's
not like a decisive advantage or
anything like that it's still quite
solid for him
I wonder how to how to get something
going here if I move the bishop here
[Music]
that's not good huh good mouth maybe net
let's see if I didn't have this on the
radiator the cell also did not
anticipate
I scored c5 no I didn't do that
I absolutely anticipate no single move
not one move
yeah hey this looks wrong somehow but
don't see - don't see how to refute it
like something on the third-ranked we
would pin this yeah everyone see three
or so but before actually just before
yep I'm under upon so I was winning the
night so second place the main purpose
of the stream was of course to just test
it switch on sunlight
yeah I'm still probably not on featured
on the front page right no yeah we got
to get this on the road no I made I made
a wrong move on him
ah shout-out to no joke chess hi there
yeah this is very lame em what I played
here was very lame I kind of made a yeah
what we call finger filo and I'm in a
line that I have no clue about but I
came it's not a big deal but I have
absolutely nothing night's you for
probably
I would like to get this and Bishop f4
no not Bishop therefore it's kind of
interesting because I mean I'm trapping
this if I go g3 and take-take-take it's
probably not that great actually
thanks for for putting me on the front
page maybe we'll get some get some
viewers in them I'm taking this get some
viewers on the stream
it was kinda kind of him to give me give
me that piece um yeah g3 is still
trapping this and now I think I can trap
it for real here yeah how often do I
stream on Twitch yeah this is the first
stream after a long long break but I'm
seriously thinking
oops say give me the Queen he is I'm
seriously thinking of doing this more
often basically doing my recording some
that are on YouTube at the end doing it
on the live to a Twitter stream why not
and it gives some additional options
simply people quite often message me so
why don't you do it on Twitch I would
like to subscribe and things like that
so why not yeah I'm going for a hedgehog
set up an idea Vader to be totally safe
against Quincy to business Queen here
yeah White has played in a very solid
fashion nothing I could have taken on f3
first which I probably should have done
simply to get some sort of imbalance
going okay I'm quite okay with this
position it's nothing nothing terrible
happening oh he wants to trade down the
whole water Queen b3 no and it was very
much to be expected
today I have a good queen day on d5 but
I'm trying to use the try to play on
some weaknesses here on the Queen side
Queenie for no okay now a d5 gets who is
doing something don't expect that the
one d5 with the unprotected bishop on e7
hmm yeah Ruby age cannot do this
aha where do we go white as white is
okay here right it's not in such bad
shape
d5 now is an interesting I can take take
Quincy - maybe okay so I can go look b8
after all kind of uncertain how I can
get something active on the rhodium I am
taking a pawn I mean I think it's just
equal
I'm not sure about this if this is a
good idea
I just want to fight for those dark
squares yeah that's probably good news
okay then I can take and take hereand I
have okay one I have no square for the
friggin Queen he didn't do it
okay it would have been a problem
absolutely
I checked the 'if one night so Queen
takes e4 c-47 rook takes e4 should work
I know I can't know I can click there
interesting
so this one check the rook and threaten
rook e8 rukia head I have 696 covering
the rook push
yeah that's a woman where you gives get
some additional beverage amount of tea
that's not good
you know it's straightest trade stuff
down isn't made that isn't made yeah
that's a cute one
yeah chick yeah
Knight takes rook e1 mate it's nice okay
I'm still second place behind old block
did won't draw hit me and okay so what
does tougher do Tafel yeah going for the
Colorado you know if I go it's pretty
awful to Colorado but berserk
yeah I don't know I just I just win the
games and hope things work out well he
doesn't play him this doesn't at some
point she gets I think he gets four fade
at him I think an entirely show
hmm huh can I don't that okay okay
yeah this is some this is kind of
acceptable for blanket not such a okay
he has to close the chapter to get faded
so um yeah no black is okay yeah right I
played this probably in somewhat in
somewhat to tame fashion but it's
certainly okay for white a for Bishop C
form something like that I need what's
up with this pieces what is wrong with
the pieces something wrong
okay and this is a slightly slightly
awkward pin
maybe defy them okay
centralized they are blurred I don't I
don't think so
there they are not blood and it's
probably something to do with the your
resolution or anything or I don't know
I'm streaming in seven I don't know a
720p it should be that should be okay
okay so let's get the e5 pawn maybe you
need to refresh twitch I'm not a really
an expert on twitch
yeah I keep them a five rook active and
I'm simply threatening to take on age
six this check is also that's made okay
so yeah I have overtaken all block by
the way I've never understood how this
is determined
uh-huh how are you an old student of
mine okay I cannot guess I guess who you
are from the name so I'm going for a
modern defense against Andrew Andrew
Caesar this is a better position is
better for white but yeah I somehow
stumbled into this okay
of course I remember you
yeah this is not not so noisy for me
maybe if I can yeah I can exactly this
is why I was thinking of take take 97
and a night to see five this is maybe
somewhat acceptable maybe it is so
better for white no okay seven things
like that yeah this will be on YouTube I
think it should be even automatically go
to youtube but I have to check this out
again this is quite new
yeah yeah he's giving me the exchange
yeah it is a really really really good
night on c5 but I have to take the
exchange what irritates me heavily is
that a queen a 595 that could still
issue to a Nisshin I needed to activate
the night maybe I should I have to sort
of plate Queen ship before that would
have yeah this is a tie the night down a
little bit and and this the board is cut
off no um I don't think so I don't have
a cut of wood in my stream preview
I just have to be as annoying as
possible here with wine tonight g-form
and the queen is attacking both pieces
is quite awkward it okay and I can take
f2 now it's their trick night each who
are something this is probably the
moment where I should use all the pieces
rugby - yeah no I think yes the right
hand side is cut off a little bit that's
true I have to adjust this a little bit
so you know that looks like meters meat
is coming I don't see it maybe there is
no immediate meat
Quincy form very difficult for whites
you're not you allow us some immediate
made so let's just use everything here
cake screen takes is made now that's all
yeah I wonder if I can actually adjust
that easily with the window with the
window
yeah I can actually wait I can actually
try this and this is a little bit better
I think yeah yeah it's a little bit
better
berserk
now I'm not pizookie I cannot I'm really
not good at that I can actually do it in
blitz here here right yeah this is
actually not that bad what what why did
him the line that you played is not very
promising but it's not super terrible if
you place it like this
okay my idea is f5f form yeah okay I
mean Black is fine of course okay f5
Bishop d5 that's kind of embarrassing
myself not let's not do that now I can
do this yeah maybe night h4 is still an
issue yeah I am I'm just I'm just
pushing forward here trying to get a
quick win here you let's go him that he
for next efore 95 should be good should
be quite strong
let's stop that I don't think shaving
your head will improve your writing I
already had a good reading before I did
that
now there's a title to Rena tomorrow oh
I have to check that I might actually be
able to do that because the I don't have
that many I don't have even English
tomorrow I think
yeah Bishop h2 main tenets actually
tough to prevent so I'm three points
ahead and we have two minutes left
yeah tight arena assaults nice I have to
have to check out exactly it's 10 p.m.
Oh can p.m. my time
are there how it's bullet right I would
like it would be nice to have it to have
them a blitz tournament tournament
pairings are close so it doesn't mean
that I have one no one we can actually
look at this right just so chess
spectral if he wins this he wins the
tournament etc so what does he have here
yeah we have a year's winning position I
guess likes King is very unsafe but
black needs to survive 50 something
seconds does he just I can Tourette
eclis speaking let the clock run down I
don't know now black prefers to move and
blunder the game okay so is it important
and I don't really know the rules and I
think if there if the clock here is over
yeah if we are on zero is it over or the
candy or can you like win after the
clock is is run down
okay so black and yeah I don't think
black will be checkmated in five seconds
that would be would be quite surprising
so I think I probably have one it yeah
so I actually wonder thing okay that's
nice and what else do we have here yeah
I mean I have established that that the
whole streaming arm works nice but let's
see what what actually can we do here
yeah I can play just I can just play
games of course but what I'm I'm no
tournament yeah the other tournaments
here I'm not going to play the hyper
bullet arena I can tell you I can tell
you that no that that's too much for me
okay so they have a broadcast feature on
leeches where it's a broadcast a
broadcast so we have to tell estilo okay
okay I can give you some some
information and what I think if you like
so this is actually the game that's nice
that they have that already here so we
have Magnus playing Magnus playing
cronic so do we have we have a of those
so we have them have an Italian game
yeah this is kind of
is one of the ways let's say to play
this Black has a wide range of cross
colleges the whole line is notoriously M
this is notoriously boring to be honest
I don't really I mean I can get this
with black and I'm not really a fan to
be honest it's always it always feels
like white has a little something the
reason why white has a little something
is actually we still have a cut-off
there on the screen but better I know
then we call it kind of the left side
yeah but I think it's it's it's quite
it's quite okay yeah after the engine on
I don't know if you've you if you like
that or if I should switch it off I
don't know yeah anyway the reason why
this is a little bit better for white is
white has a bit more space and you have
the pawns here the pawns are more
flexible blacks pawns can also easily be
used to gain space and one one and one
problem is that the knight on c6 I can
switch it off I mean I don't mind and
the knight on c6 is in a somewhat in a
somewhat bad spot because it looks at
many squares actually that are covered
or control chair like oops I didn't want
to do that I just want to UM paint um
yeah like the knight doesn't have many
squares oftentimes it will try to
reroute like their Bishop a7 Quincy -
yeah white goes for the classic Knight
maneuver - g3 and Kramnik gets d5 in so
yeah certainly makes sense to gain a bit
of space there in the center and now
Magnus has taken yeah that's an
interesting decision first first glance
you think that doesn't look that
fantastic because yeah like hands
pressure here and see you plays Bishop
III so we get this big trade-off here
black ticks here and white chicks here
ninety-five of now 94 so yeah the
question is said equal or is black still
suffering a little bit no black black
it's not equal here this is the this is
the thing this is not only annoying from
blackness this opening but it also is
not entirely equal then sometimes
positions like that that feel a little
bit awkward you know for example if
black decides to take here white could
could go for this and this is never
equal because this is a fantastic square
for the night covering here looking to
jump here it's it's very nice now black
also will not play that I'm pretty sure
about it yeah you can take here that
gives YDE file also not not completely
also not completely fine here like
taking on c3 it's an interesting
question
currently don't see why why couldn't
have played it that's actually okay
this is the thing you need to think for
a moment about this yeah look at this
look at snow squares yeah it's nice it
cover-to-cover to commit yeah
everything is covered and the only
squares that are not covered immediately
here or here jump into this so this is
an exchange that's nice that's neat
yeah a nice night night retreats are
often easily overlooked yeah I mean this
is this is hanging but the look here
hanging first so couldn't have done that
yeah I think mangas are slightly better
him so okay Dwayne Jones against onigiri
what do we have here okay so we have a
Kuro pun of attack you don't see this
opening that often in top-level play
somehow if you get caro-kann they mostly
play the advanced variation but the
panel of fear and this is opening here
it's not a bad choice I often recommend
that to students if they look for like
open please play in the car oh you get
that if you have an wide open position
where you can calculate variations yeah
so here um yeah Johnson I takes d5 is a
little bit of a it's a bit surprising
that he would play that
that looks a little bit unambitious that
same to take on d5 I mean you have to
watch out yeah like maybe has this idea
that looking at this and at the same
time attacking d4 it's not yeah I mean
if you do this for example that could be
an issue I'm not sure if this is a real
problem but d4 hangs a3 could be an idea
to prevent this and that belongs into
this position anyway yeah I'm sorry it
was a wrong button
so he took on d5 and give me took with
the pawn okay and it looks like a very
very safe choice buying by Dwayne Jones
I mean here is the rating underdog in
that in that tournament and he's
certainly fine with solid positions I
don't know how he did so far I think he
lost the game against ye the last round
year round before that but okay so I
think it looks fairly normal
be free and now Queen to f6 okay
but that would be quite surprising if
that's not going to end in the draw and
it's really really boring him if anybody
I would rather be black but I think it's
very equal okay let's go so Adi gone
what was that some English opening
problem yeah yeah okay black is Adi by
now he plays some some enterprising
stuff him but should be several and this
is interesting an interesting way of
playing actually for black and then f5
the the thing about this is it looks it
looks a little bit odd maybe but it is
quite okay if white plays in a very lame
fashion if white no place let's say d3
or yeah very lame let's same does it
actually work with lines yeah it does
yeah d3 let let's say I'm doing
something something slow I mean I'm not
saying that one that's terrible for what
I just want to show the idea then black
is going to or can play stuff like that
it looks a little bit like the classical
Dutch this is this line with d66 and so
on but like already has it you five in
in one move and if things work out
really well yeah black can get this F
for Bishop h3 this cage man detectors
quite dangerous so this is some yeah
this is not so terrible it's quite an
interesting line I've played it once and
turned my chess myself
yeah d4 was plate and this is what I
mean you have to have to do something
might have six to keep the tension and
now so went for the endgame Jim really
my am my recommendation was b3 in my
English opening repertoire okay capture
capture c6 air to get the bishop one to
see several yeah here black is I think
okay the center is slightly vulnerable
but which it cannot be cannot be all
that great okay so before played by
anybody no egos F floor mouth and for is
surprising there maybe he has problems
to get this to some someplace him okay I
want to find let's focus on the actual
position this white whoa what okay
I'm sorry I don't understand the move
okay that wasn't play but I'd like to
understand what happens here you know
you go here huh
sorry I don't get it I mean okay
yeah yeah it's not it's not completely
out of this out of this world because we
if Y takes here and you take c7 that's
the thing yeah
so the Night Moves okay and let's say I
try without the cambia for them or for
the moment let's say here yeah we take
with the night I don't think because
that doesn't threaten much I was
thinking this let me just try a like
here I was thinking this move and now
I'm attacking here and I'm attacking on
f6 now if black grabs here we can I
don't know take here probably first him
I mean that that's that's excellent for
white yeah maybe you can also just do
this yeah this is this is excellent for
white and that before is probably the
same thing I just wanted about this what
is the what is the thing here I was
thinking 95 maybe because here all kinds
of things are hanging this is this
I mean if you have just imagined such a
position here okay Bishop f7 does this
actually work okay okay well yeah I can
I can even do this I guess yeah there
are a couple of things that would work
interesting stuff okay so now let's
let's that's let's recheck what the
engine is saying yeah it does the same
thing I like here and 95 you know after
a while it will probably understand that
white is quite okay with this what I
what I gave I think this is I have three
is right okay
I mean this b6 before yeah that's
interesting stuff
currently the engine is not only a very
convinced about test I mean it's only on
depth 20 years or so much but it's still
quite quite a surprise okay with what
happened so black takes and then he went
III okay
hmm
still doesn't want to take it yeah okay
so we have this position on the board
huh interesting
yeah first glance you would think white
is substantially better with the bishop
pair but it's a tricky situation somehow
this is also currently quite annoying
Bishop d6 Anna looks like an immediate
idea maybe not the best move but
interesting yeah I would think that so
it's better yeah unless I'm we're
looking something really really concrete
that same what does the engine say 56
roughly zero point something 0.2 okay ma
clock off Kuryakin
I always think and what I always do is
when I see a position I try to guess
what opening that was I'm guessing that
was some Reggie opening it wasn't ready
opening okay Kings Indian attack
yeah it's the question is that slightly
better for wide or is that equal yeah
okay why don't take with the pawn and
yeah White has b5 and in for these are
the idea set to get this Bishop a bit
more active this this looks like a
sensible idea at first but I think my
form looks pretty awkward now that looks
awkward okay what is that work he
actually if I go back here so so chrome
leg actually went for this endgame I
went to b5 and this is okay this is a
point yeah that's a good point
I mean white is still better here at
least some somewhat better but AFI was
interesting because what kramnik is
doing yeah he tries to if Black gets to
take you get maybe this night out to a
better Square and then this is an idea
or or this as well and you have looks
not that okay
you have look see if I awesome is this
idea which is probably it could be the
movie actually yeah but but I think
Carson is quite happy here this is a
nice game okay if we go back here
briefly like here here white will go
before I guess this this kind of
position can easily trade down to
absolutely nothing if like this this
cluster of pawns can easily be traded
off I think it's probably roughly what I
would I would rather be white but some
yeah okay yes the star still just
quickly going through the games
um what is that Momiji on of Quran okay
can they go for a sideline here in the
Queen's Gambit with Knight bTW - ok yeah
so Carmona is snatching this pawn and
keeps the pawn oops I'm sorry was the
Miss kick a three so Khurana did not
manage to keep that pawn but rather
gated back for coordination so this is
the position okay
yeah I said is that said equal I know
good people
I don't think white has anything special
there on the on the King on any problem
with the King positioning with a double
prong can you look at the points there
white iam this is always an issue my
black black should be funny I think so
we have then we have Svidler against we
found okay that was a quick skim but
Agana yeah so we have a hard spot
structure 95 95 I'm surprised about but
okay white can still go for the
Pillsbury 95 therefore setup certainly
possible night age 5 who one night each
Pfeiffer has a couple of ideas main idea
could be 97 Bishop f5 to trade this or
somebody play of six kicks the night
away b-17 and Queen a for create for
some mysterious move what is Queen a for
doing
preparing before oh I don't know
Queen aphorism is a surprising choice I
don't know what Queen a4 does is he
preparing this it would be a funny idea
yeah
I'm just just for fun yeah like this is
actually not that not that uninteresting
for why do you have to a pawns I can
push this and you can actually play on
those two files em it's it's it's not
completely out of the question we've
seen that was ideas with Queen a3
there's if there's a famous case of a
game Ireland to Paula from the 2012
World Championship match 2012 no 20 2010
I'm sorry okay and we have Vishy Anand
against ye okay this is going to be a
draw that's it's a draw that was a that
was a Petrov right yeah
no surprise there yeah this is this line
the official oops I'm sorry about that
that was too quick this line here with
Bishop f5 and we should be 7y currently
has absolutely zilch against and island
it's just that doesn't have an ID I am
against this seems
okay yeah sorry to tell you but this is
all theory the whole game is cerium they
already made a draw I guess they already
made a draw
yeah I actually prepared that with black
for game against a strong GM know the
the the petrol of the Russian defense
can be extremely boring its Pakistan
yeah black is basically yeah not afraid
of having simplified symmetrical
position and if white does not have
anything great in store it's going to be
that boring yep ok so let's see okay so
we had this a 5f 396 yeah again white is
slightly better I think this is yeah
this was a very very boring yeah no it's
it's tough to imagine now that maybe
it's we will just simply trade
everything now yeah Bishop d2 I've got
rook c8 they could take and I think
there's a good likelihood that you don't
need to be 2642 draw that with white
against giving yeah I don't know if you
really want to win both black and I know
if decisions like he takes d5 or Queen
f6 if they help all that much yeah okay
so here Bishop d6 was played and somehow
Matlock off I know this is a draw
okay I'm sorry this is why they have
they have already drawn here okay
interesting I wonder why why is that to
do that don't they have a good anti draw
rule here it's a bit bit surprising I
mean I mentioned that I feel the
position is somewhat equal it's
surprising to that they have a draw
ok here King h8 back r1 okay okay J Ruby
idea you can try swin a form and who you
find a thinking about it yeah okay so
let's see you I want to check is there
some quick tournament that I could play
there are only hyper bullets around I
don't want to play in hyper bullet but
that's really really too stressful
okay yeah I think actually I'm going to
wrap it up here I'm happy that the whole
streaming um thing worked from a
technical point of view and I'm looking
forward to stream some more I want to
check something though when exactly is
that is the title tournament I want to
see that I can I can scroll here somehow
right to this yeah okay where's that I
got to oh and this is can I see that
somewhere shouldn't this titles here
entitled arena here
[Music]
so when do we start at 10:00 p.m. I can
actually do that
yeah I can actually do that so I can I
can I can put myself up on this and try
to do this tomorrow it should work it
should really work I think I don't have
any don't of any appointment there so um
yeah one thing is actually necessary I
need a stable internet connection which
wasn't actually that that is it the same
no I will I will stream I will certainly
stream not just to record it I think
yeah it's bullet unfortunately I would
have liked a bridge tournament but okay
it's it's fun I know they are very
strong those tournaments so I'm probably
not going to win it is that actually on
the rest day out of Tata Steel it's
noisy em maybe they will play yeah they
will play and there will be someone
playing okay guys thanks a lot for
watching the stream I'm happy that it
worked out fine and yeah I'm going to
wrap it up here I have a later
livestream by the way um form a chest 24
that's going to be on the chest 24
YouTube channel and on the chest 24
websites so going to play Ben tablets
I'm starting in two and a half hours so
if you have time yeah make sure to join
it but we will also be fun yeah thanks a
lot for watching bye bye for today